hey Scott hey Andy I was going good we
just got to see the crew wild run
expansion and we wanted to bring back
three reasons that people might be
excited to be back into the crew and the
first one that stood out to me
motorcycles motorcycles definitely like
very different gameplay it was cool we
got a chance to ride around some
motorcycles do all kinds of different
things
DC time trials just rode through the
desert on one for some reason had to
like pull a wheelie for a certain amount
of time and keep oh yeah they're like
you know the ambient crew challenges and
what it was like Pappa wheelie with your
team you know um so it was really cool
to see such you know a substantial
addition cuz it really does kind of
change the way the game plays I mean
when I got a motorcycle not the same is
driving around in a car no not at all
but like the cars you can spec it out
into like all the different types of
things the crew does like have for the
car specs so you have like performance
or just factory or off-road although
they didn't show us the off-road they
assured us that it's gonna be in there
and you can go through the whole game
with the bike yeah one of the cool
things about this pack I mean it
actually introduces a I think for for
different types of vehicles including
bikes and they can all be used in any
facet of the game which is which is
actually pretty cool because you can go
back and replay older content with new
vehicles and it might play a little
differently might let you get a little
more out of it stay introduced drift
cars freakin drag racing like all the
stuff and those are all kind of
encapsulated nicely in the summit events
and monster truck monster
oh yeah monster trucks are a big one too
which are also really cool I mean that's
exactly what it sounds like you're
literally driving around in a car with
you know giant 20-foot no that's too big
ten-foot wheels maybe 20 foot or no they
had a they had a park that was basically
a skate park for cars that the monster
trucks were going in yeah it's a
predators in like stairs and you could
do back yeah there's a literal halfpipe
that you could drive your monster truck
through it was pretty great and there's
actually like a point new point system
but yeah a lot of this is related to the
new event system ring yes number two
which is the summit and that was like
kind of a horizon festival but like just
more ridiculous and just a way it's just
a way to like get you to do these events
I think yeah what it really comes down
to is it's a way of frame
a bunch of new event types but it is
sort of a physical location within the
game world but but really it's like a
Coachella style racing event it's a
little confusing the way that it was
presented to us but I think once you get
in game it'll actually make a lot of
sense and the key thing is that there's
going to be not only you know new mo
types to match with these new people's
there's also going to be weekly content
coming directly from the developers
contests
you know races just new stuff to do
every week related to the summit if
those races like don't work for you or
whatever you can create this is the
third thing on our list of awesome stuff
you can actually now create custom races
using the map we're simple I mean so
he's like you know it might take a lot
of time no no no nope you just look at
the map and put a dot where you want a
waypoint to be and the game will just
like okay and it'll drop everyone at the
starting line that you set yeah and put
markers on the map and just say go and
this seems like the realization of this
game because you've got all these people
playing you've got this huge world and
now it's like okay we'll just create own
races and invite everybody in yeah this
capitalizes on everything the game
already did well yeah and yeah we got a
chance to try this as well and it had
some pretty interesting and unexpected
results I mean my favorite was and again
remember this was entirely unplanned
this is just something somebody threw
together we did an off-road race where
somebody just put random waypoints
through like a rocky environment and it
just kind of worked out that each
checkpoint was at the top of like a
rocky bottleneck and every time we got
to a checkpoint everyone was trying to
fight their way up the hill and make it
through this narrow little opening at
the top so they could get a head start
to the next checkpoint and it was kind
of cool and it was just this really
interesting emerging gameplay as people
like to say because it was it was so
unexpected it was unplanned and yet it
worked out so perfectly the terrain in
this game is actually really varied from
the mountains to the mad max-style
canyons we were racing through to the
just Normal City stuff like so building
a race anywhere you want is gonna be
insanely fun and you can like do
different cars and drift through this
thing if you want like I don't
that this seems to be like the simplest
addition but also kind of the most
exciting yeah I mean it's a classic
example of the simplest ideas are often
the best ones right I mean there's not
much to this but that freedom and the
ability to set your own checkpoints and
call it an official race and have the
game mechanically recognize what you're
doing is huge and opens all kinds of
possibilities for you know your own
types of gameplay and whatever it is
that you enjoy about the game you can
really kind of focus on that and use
that to make your own experience better
the crew wilderun expansion is dropping
on November 17th yeah I mean it seems
pretty substantial since like it has a
lot to offer so if you enjoyed the game
or looking for excuse to finally check
it out this might be it yeah all right
thanks Scott yeah thank you Andy